we now continue with our example and
turn to the performance evaluation
question as you recall we have a theta
that has a certain prior distribution
were given a model for the observations
we came up with a joint distribution for
X and theta which was uniform on this
particular shape and we found that the
least mean square system ATAR namely the
conditional expectation of theta given
any particular value of x is given by
this particular piecewise linear
function now let us look at the
performance of this estimator we judge
the performance given any particular
value of x by looking at the
corresponding mean squared error which
is the square of the distance between
the unknown parameter and the estimate
with which we came up and as we have
discussed this is the same as the
variance of theta but in the conditional
universe where X has been observed
it's the variance of the conditional
distribution of theta as we have
discussed if I tell you that X takes on
this particular value theta is uniform
on this interval therefore the
conditional variance of theta is the
variance of a uniform on an interval of
this particular length now we know that
the variance of a uniform on an interval
from A to B is equal to B minus a
squared divided by 12 in this particular
instance the interval has length 2
therefore we have 2 squared divided by
12 so the variance is equal to one-third
this is what we get when the picture is
of this type on the other hand if X
falls in this range then this interval
on which theta is now constrained to
live has a smaller length and we're
going to get a different variance so in
order to keep track let us come up with
a plot when x is between 5 & 9
theta has a conditioned distribution
which is uniform on an interval of
length 2 and the variance of 1/3 and
therefore the variance is constant takes
this value at the extreme case when X is
equal to 3 then this interval has zero
lengths in fact we have perfect
certainty about the value of theta if X
is equal to 3 then we know that theta is
equal to 4 there is no uncertainty
there's zero variance what happens in
between and as we increase X moving away
from 3 the length of this interval
increases linearly with X and this means
that the variance increases
quadratically with X so we have a
quadratic that starts at 0 and rises to
this value and by symmetric argument
on the other side we also get a function
which is 0 at 11 and which rises
quadratically as X gets reduced from 11
to 9 so this is a complete plot of the
conditional variance of theta as a
function of the particular observation
that we have obtained we notice that
some X's are more favorable than others
an observation equal to 3 is extremely
favorable because it tells us
unambiguously the value of theta but
other choices of X other possible
observations we lead to more uncertainty
in theta and this is reflected in this
diagram in case we're now interested in
the overall mean squared error then we
have to calculate the average of this
conditional variance where the average
is taken over all values of X this is
going to be an integral of the
conditional variance of theta integrated
over all possibilities for X but of
course each possibility of X has to be
weighted
according to the corresponding
probability or in this case probability
density function of X what is the PDF of
X it is not given to us but it is
something that can be easily determined
from what we have already done
we know the Joint Distribution of theta
and X and whenever we know the joint we
can also find the marginal so once we
find the marginal PDF of X then we can
plug it in multiplied by this function
that we have already obtained carry out
the integration and we will end up with
a numerical value since it is an average
of what we have here it's going to end
up being some number between 0 and 1/3
it's the average of these values and
closer to 1/3 rather than to 0 and this
would complete the way that the
performance of a particular estimator
gets evaluated